I'm getting hit with some major Whiplash
going from Velma to the last of us
because it's from the absolute bottom of
the barrel to the peak of entertainment
The Last of Us episode 1 blew away my
expectations because it elevates the
source material which was already
outstanding on its own in this day and
age great adaptions are rare because it
requires the writers of the show to have
a thorough understanding of what made
the source material great and how to
properly translate it to the new medium
Craig Mason who is a showrunner is doing
an amazing job so far and The Last of Us
may have the potential to rival
Chernobyl which was his last project and
that is an insane statement to make on
its own from how perfect that miniseries
was also since they have Neil druckman
helping with the scripts it really goes
to show that they want to be as
respectful to the source material as
possible and to be authentic for the
show it's able to build off the rich
world of the game and add in scenes that
further flesh out the world along with
having more scenes dedicated to
character development and altering
perspectives that you can't really do in
a game because you are tied to a
singular point of view as an example we
have more scenes with Ellie did build
her up a little more and to allow us to
sympathize with her quicker on top of
great world building like the meeting
with the fireflies and then briefly
going over their objectives this scene
was technically Exposition driven but it
didn't feel boring at all because the
writers are putting a lot of emphasis on
the characters these people despite
being in only a couple of small scenes
have more personality than most other
main characters from other shows these
additional scenes that aren't in the
game really stand out to me and is what
impressed me because of how much value
they add like the first scene alone was
actually one of my favorite scenes from
the episode besides obviously the tragic
fate of Sarah which was just as good as
it was in the game but I want to First
appreciate the new content within the
show this cold open is a master class of
a scene within itself something that
Craig Mason does really well is instill
a sense of drag within the audience
there's a lot of different factors that
goes into this like the cinematography
getting Tighter and more claustrophobic
by pushing it on close-ups as the scene
addresses shots focusing on the audience
to reveal their scared reactions to us
and the music slowly building and
permeating in the background to make you
feel uneasy
we lose
along with the monologue that the
scientist delivers being expertly
written a small detail I loved was how
the scene first starts out with a bit of
Comedy but as the doctor goes through
his speech he even rattles the
interviewer which is really rare and
makes this occasion even more unsettling
I also just found the whole fungi
Revelation really intriguing and is
honestly one of the most believable
reasons for a zombie outbreak in the
game I don't remember them explicitly
explaining the reason for the outbreak
and you know it has to do with fungus
but for the show it further fleshes out
this aspect within the world and adds to
the source material so right away Craig
Mason creates a tense atmosphere and
writes an original scene with so much
weight and expertise that it instantly
engaged me and made me excited for
what's to come because this show offers
more than just a carbon copy of the
original game the cold open was also
followed by a great opening title
sequence in particular I love how it
looked like the fungus was spreading
through America and I'm really glad that
they're using the original score from
the game another original scene or
scenes that loved was Sarah's
relationship with her neighbors this
again elevates and builds upon the game
since the opening of the game and
quickly throws you into the outbreak in
the car sequence for the show they were
able to build more suspense through this
development and one of my favorite shots
from the first episode that achieved
this was when Sarah was looking at the
DVDs and the old lady behind her started
having facial contortions just an
excellent shot that is very creative
through its users of hiding a subject
with focus it gives off this feeling of
Discovery within the frame and further
scares you as a viewer when you notice
what is happening in the background
along with not really getting a detailed
view as to what is happening so it
further gets under your skin in the shot
after this where Sarah's positioning
within the frame blocking the door
behind her creates the feeling that she
may get approached from behind just
through these two shots alone I'm
already in love with the cinematography
which the cinematography overall for the
first episode was beautiful the design
of the show is also just Immaculate and
allows the cinematographer to get some
incredible footage the production design
is filled to the brim with detail and
there's so much storytelling being done
with just the environment alone this
makes me really excited for the next
episode to see how the set pieces look
when they are in the rundown City this
atmosphere with a guitar Centric score
playing in the background is so goddamn
good and gives me great memories from my
playthrough of the game since I was
already gushing about how good the
writing is I want to further acknowledge
how intelligent the script is there's so
many moments that don't hold your hand
in terms of what's happening and allows
if you were to fully engage with the
show moments like the child going
through the Boston checkpoint and US
figuring out that he or she is infected
at this point we don't know exactly how
the tests work despite it being read so
ironically this girl officer confirms
through over exaggerated kindness what
the fate of the kid is also to point out
a brilliant edit the end of the scene
hard cuts to the bonfire bodies which to
me implied that the kid died but they
did bring him or her out so that they
could punctuate how far gone and
detached Joel currently is another
clever moment in the writing was the
ending with the radio through a bit of
character development and showing that
Ellie is sharp and observant she tries
to fill in the missing piece for the
radio code and figures out that 80s
music means trouble so since we retained
that bit of information it turns on
again playing a song from the 80s which
then builds and climaxes at the end of
the episode this rewards the viewer for
paying attention and gives them that
moment of ah I get it then even the
dialogue for the characters feels very
natural and likable an example I liked
was Joel and Sarah having breakfast and
joking about how there are eggshells in
the eggs it becomes a quick recurring
joke for them in this scene and builds
their close relationship in the game it
starts with Sarah giving Joel his
birthday present so the show is able to
further build the relationship between
them and that thus makes their ending
even more devastating because they have
a stronger Bond it's kind of surprising
really how much new content there is
within the first half hour because it
all perfectly fits into the source
material and feels like a natural
extension that aids it like looking at
the game that prologue only lasts about
5 15 minutes and in the show we don't
get to the time Jump until the 35 minute
Mark then for the escape in the truck it
was perfectly done the sense of dread by
this point was built up so much to the
point that even if he played the game he
probably felt some form of anxiety me
and my girlfriend play through the last
of us together and even she was getting
nervous through this scene despite
knowing their outcome also the execution
of this scene was as close as you could
possibly get to the game and if anything
I think they actually improved it with a
plane crash those planes looming over
the characters and deafening them
further increased attention and made the
scene even more frightening so when one
finally crashed it was a literal great
explosive climax for the game they end
up getting hit by a car which then flips
their vehicle so for the show I think
this was definitely a step up to a
degree when Joel eventually runs into
the infected it was absolutely metal how
crazy they were and how they were
running Full Tilt into things it makes
the sense for that scene very impressive
and it reminded me of World War Z which
this then leads into the Dead death of
Sarah and it was as emotionally pungent
as it was in the game Pedro Pascal is a
perfect Joel and his heartbreaking
moment was Sarah left me floored and on
the verge of tears even though I've
already played through this moment then
Bella Ramsey so far is doing a stellar
job as Ellie her opening scene quickly
establishes her character and was a
funny bit of writing her and Jordan
integral part of what makes the last of
us so amazing and so far from the brief
moments they shared together it's pretty
promising if anything there's one small
change they made that I don't know if a
lot of people noticed but it's the
circumstances in which Sean Ellie meets
are a bit more negative like how Joel
constantly has a gun trained on Ellie
while in the game she does come at them
with a knife but she opens up a bit more
to them so in the show I like how
there's a bit more starting friction and
I'm excited to see how the relationship
blossoms from here so overall the first
episode of The Last of Us essentially
blows any other video game adaption out
of the water so much to the point that
there's basically no competition I'm
just really happy they didn't try to
turn this into a movie and are actually
dedicating an entire series to telling
the story thank you for watching and
right now I'm leaning towards covering
the show weekly given that it's actually
really good and probably has some
carryover from The Game of Thrones crowd
since both shows are in HBO Max If I Do
cover the show weekly I'll also try to
fit in some other videos so I'm not just
doing The Last of Us for the next two
months